monorails are a sleek cool and
futuristic mode of transportation
but we don't seem to have many of them
running around in fact when compared to
conventional rail
monorails are almost non-existent and so
why is that well monorails actually tie
into this
contemporary agitation that all our
problems will be solved by
tech bros and their magic high-tech
solutions behind [ __ ] projects such
as the hyperloop or the boring company
loop
monorails are next in line and so why is
that
why are monorails such a bad idea
despite there being relatively
successful systems operating today
alright so problem number one of
basically any monorail system
is cross-compatibility meaning that if
you build a monorail line
only monorail trains will be able to run
on it which in practice limits your
system to a very specific passenger
train set
and so this here is a photo sphere image
of the otsuka station in tokyo
you can see the passenger platform and
the two tracks adjacent to it but next
to it there's another pair of tracks
now during my stay in tokyo i used to
take the ammonite line from this station
in the morning i would often see freight
trains going past the station on that
adjacent pair of tracks
now if this was a purely monorail system
this of course would not be possible but
then you could say oh well that's easy
let's just build a monorail and then
leave next to it two pairs of
conventional rare tracks so that both
freight trains and monorail trains can
run
but that idea doesn't really work either
the third and the fourth tracks are used
to divert trains too
should there be a problem with the first
or the second you know if the train
breaks down or something or if a switch
goes out
then trains can go around the station
you know of course if you had two
monorail tracks and two conventional
rail tracks you're kind of stuck with
those two you cannot divert any of the
trains to any other tracks
whereas with a fully conventional rail
system you could just switch them over
speaking of which problem number two
switches
now this might seem like a banal thing
at first but monorail switches are one
of the most
awkward and contrived things you can
build in transportation
if that thing gets stuck during
switching or there's any other
malfunction
the entire monorail line would need to
be shut down for hours possibly
so that the repair team can actually get
out there and somehow reach the
malfunction switch
which would most likely include
industrial alpinist stunts
now in contrast if a conventional rail
switch goes out it's much easier to
reach and the problem is usually
resolved within one hour
and if it's an older construction you
can either send the mic out to hammer it
back into place
so that the next train can pass and then
just fix it properly later
passing a monorail switch is also
excruciatingly slow whereas in europe
there are conventional rail switches
certified for 200 kilometers per hour
and that is not the speed for going
straight through it that's the speed at
which the actual switching between the
tracks happens
and so problem number three of monorails
is that they have to be completely
elevated
and so if you look at these schematics
comparing conventional rail to bottom
supported monorail to suspended monorail
we can see that monorail tracks
regardless of where they are require
a significant amount of track
infrastructure namely that they have to
be elevated even on the surface
and underground and this poses a rather
serious problem
you see surface level rail
infrastructure is the cheapest of the
three
and so when we build rail lines we try
to build as much as possible
on the surface but with monorail these
cost savings are impossible
because as you can see both on the
surface and underground you have to
build infrastructure
as if you are building elevated rail
with some corresponding construction
costs of course
so this means that over long distances
where you would lead the rails on the
ground
monorail is just not viable so if you
wanted to build a monorail line you
would need to find a section where
only elevated rails are possible which
in most cities is extremely rare
after all the vast majority of public
transit rail lines go either partially
underground or on the ground
but even if there was a section in your
city where only elevated lines were
possible
you still have to deal with problem
number four maintenance
now monorail maintenance itself is not
particularly costly
however as we discussed there are very
few places where it makes actual sense
to build a monorail
so if you have a transport company that
has say 10 light rail lines and they
want to build a new line between the
city center and the airport
and a fully elevated line would make
actual sense on that section
it still makes very little sense to
build a monorail line
because if you already have a
pre-existing light rail system you
should probably build a line where you
can run rolling stock you already have
otherwise you would need to invest in an
entire new maintenance depot in specific
repair equipment
retraining personnel to maintain the
monorail trains all this extra effort
and money
just for one single line and this is of
course something that no sensible
company would do
moving on the fifth biggest problem with
monorails seems to be capacity
now it is entirely possible to build a
monorail system capable of transporting
a lot of people
however the previously mentioned
problems relegate the monorail to very
specific locations
and because of this the monorail can not
really operate at high capacities
as mass transit should and so let's take
the sydney monorail as an example
it operated between 1988 and 2013
carrying 70 million passengers during
this time
the system had six trains running
between 8 stations
on a 3.6 kilometer long line now 70
million passengers over the course of 26
years sounds like a lot
and this also happens to be the number
of passengers that the budapest m3
metroline carries
in five months and it can do that by
having
six times more trains two times more
stations and a line which is about five
times longer and this produces a 70
times difference between ridership
numbers and all of this in a city which
is less than
third of sydney's size now the m3 line
has a ridership
similar to the line 3 of the chongqing
rail transit which is supposed to be the
busiest monorail line in the world
and the chongqing line 3 monorail can
achieve these numbers
by being four times longer and having
more than twice as many stations
now of course this is not meant to be a
direct comparison there are other
factors in place such as how the city is
laid out
where the line is led and so on but i
wanted to show you how
disproportionately low the monorail's
capacity is compared to conventional
rail
as in you have to build out a ton of
infrastructure even in a chinese
metropolis to surpass the passenger
account of a metro line in a 1.7 million
european city
so to recap the five main problems of
monorails are cross compatibility
switches the need for the track to be
completely elevated
the need for costly parallel maintenance
infrastructure
and low capacity compared to heavy rail
or even light rail
so why do some cities build monorails
well
mostly because they are considered to be
sleek and futuristic
even though you could achieve similar
passenger numbers on a proposed line by
just running two dozen of those little
rubber wheeled sightseeing trains
actually if you had a line where you ran
a dozen of those things and each carried
at least 50 people per hour for 12 hours
per day
you would produce the same annual
ridership numbers as the sydney monorail
monorails in general seem to be a
version of this stack bro
future transit drift which produces
overpriced
overhyped and yet very low capacity
transit which are at the end of the day
for the few and not for the many go
figure
and that's the reason why monorails are
a bad idea
alright so this was my hot take on
monorails
don't forget to like and subscribe and
if you feel like this content is worth
your money then there is a patreon link
down in the description
your patronage is very much appreciated
in the meantime
i'll be seeing you when i'll see you